那么一个十二年的游动机
一口是我觉得在所有的皮膚问题里面
最好继续觉得
但现在我发现还有很多女生都不会去立口
我点上如果有立口我配上他们实现就得点上消失
今天就是一期手把手的去立口交身
会有一点长
但是这一次我会把我做的和我用的全部的记录下来
希望爱掌立口的朋友都可以在心态玩
你知道原理和证据的操作固装之后
就可以让立口不处理人生了
先两件一下去立口的原理
立口就是油脂嫁老肺的脚制度住毛孔
还会发火的斗斗
一旦不管他或者你外利的去计压
他就会像火山爆发一样变成红种大斗斗
会留下很深的印子
所以将发现脸上有立口的时候
控制住手
我要乱几
这样可以防止他变成红种大斗留下很深的印子
并二部针轻后口就好了
就可以开始用酸了
酸可以收通毛孔
加速代谢防止立口反风涨
那有立口的时候
我要用酸有鼻后的手用酸
他就会吹鼠
并成红种大斗斗斗斗斗
这就是很多简美用酸烂脸的原因
第三点也是非常重要的
就是我们在真轻之后的五到七天做一次
家庭百元秀
他可以防止我们的毛孔斗塞
坚持做里面长闭口的那个油脂都没有了
直接就从根源处把闭口解决了
那现在我们就开始进行七天的根练了
第一天就是去真轻
有很多简美会害怕真轻
我这次带你们与体验下真轻全过程
真轻就是在你的闭口还没有变成
都都之前先扎个小洞
让里面的脚似安洞跟有出口能出来
就不会把口子弄得非常的大
基本上心碗
他都是一个小红点
好的特别快
也不会有那种很深的洞路
但是不建议自己在家里面
请手法部队闭口特别容易发火
暴斗努动动力
可以提醒买好这个领帐
真轻后让白大瓜爆买土尚
防止口子发火
真轻碗的呼呼很简单
过六个小时之后
就可以有深历的真轻
它是洗脸了
口子上还是一旧头上领澆
避开口子地方
按压一个轻爽修过的保持练装
几天晚上都稍微做一点保持就可以了
早前是第二天早上看人家
基本会否就轻烤
最有点种
第二天是关键的红红消退期
这个时候就可以用一些防止油下红
可以用自己的护服停了
我一般会准备两套修的护服停
大家可以根据自己的情况来选择
我会搭配的解门
就可以跟着我一起玩
早上起来还是用身脸嘴
它是洗脸
护服玩再在口子上继续投降这个领澆
晚上就可以用正常的温柯的洗脸来洗脸了
今天是8月4号
第一三个晚上
想一下皮不妆态
六个这两个
动动
准轻完了之后
二十几个晚上正常的情况
没有关系几天就会消下去的
第三天就是继续正常护服
如果有红种动作出现
就护服玩再统一点的领澆
有红种动作或者是冒小白点
它都是很正常的
因为机底下还有红
照常修护然后图着的领澆澆
它自己会下去的
哈喽
今天是8月5号
真期望的第四天
我觉得认识单了很多
这个大家都都就不怪他
这个也不疼了
也别下去
然后这边也淡放了很多
这边也别下去了很多
然后头基本上就很大我了
第四天依旧按照我之前增想的正常护服
但是你们交就提用了
因为这个领澆澆澆澆澆
我阿用久了
下次就没有消防了
阿姨
今天是8月6号第五天
给大家看一下我的皮膚状态
这个都都已经别掉了
这边的硬子基本上都淡掉了
然后这边淡了百分之七十吧
这个都已经完全品掉了
那个斗斗筋华真的很厉害
第五天很重要
这个时候基本上里上的口子都已经结架了
那就一定要开会服前面用上专动我了
很多人真心完还会上闭口
就是因为他直接觉得现有的
他们有去预防闭口的身长
算可以帮我们驱出油脂
收通毛孔让闭服变光滑
减少脸上的那些各个大大的
还可以减少出油的速度
我大家就可以选择一个自己
已经耐受的酸动我
酸动模服个几段钟之后
就可以去洗脚洗完之后
再继续之前的护服工程就可以了
好 今天是第六天晚上8月7号
看看第六天的皮膚状态吧
这个地方这个斗斗已经品货
但是还说点红
不管他
下巴这边的这个硬子
除了这两个其他的斗斗
淡了很多了
这边也就是这两个
两个斗斗斗是对称的
第六天就还是跟之前一样的护服非常简单
嗨 今天是第七天
经过前几天的这个密集护离
今天皮膚也挺恢复的差不多了
现在我准备做一个家庭版海的秀
给我的真心来个完美的安定
穿几把毛红里的这些油是彻底的清楚干净
但也一般有三次的清潔
所以可以非常非常深度的把我们毛孔
里面的那些藏东形的形油只都给你清出来
毛孔通常的再用护服品
它的吸收力也会更好
然后觉得护服服品用小的更效果
那这样对于一点上了动力
原本淡化的更快型
好了 期间的一个更练结束的
这是我做的一个西天的总结大家可以解图
今天是我真亲玩的第十天
给大家看看我的皮膚状态
你们跟着我这样做
喜欢两周皮膚就能护护幸运一光滑
没有麻烦了来的状态楼